terraform the moon would nights be
darker due to the lost surface
reflectivity oh yeah almost anything you
do to the moon will make it reflect more
overload is one of the worst reflecting
the moon reflects adding skyscrapers
them the moon reflects like a sidewall
tire the moon ISM is like I forgot that
it's like five percent which lays low
single-digit reflective but what if we
composition mirrors would that be
helpful what would happen to the earth
so for example earth which has oceans
and land and clouds earth is like 10
times more reflective than the moon is
oh uh and so the moon is is the bad
rough it's like dark yeah it's just so
much likely more reflective as a pancake
yeah no no it's as reflective as the
surface of an iron skillet
oh okay so anything you put there is
gonna make it more reflective Emily we
can see it because of how non reflective
iron skillet well suppose because how
bright the Sun is but it's very very
exactly so when you do this if you want
to terraform it you will make the full
moon brighter at night
oh really